bonjour est heureux de vous retrouver
pour ce nouveau c'est 8 est qu un 7,8
échos dédié cette fois au réseau
d'entreprise suite à l'événement imagine
mobility du réseau movéo qui s'est
déroulé à l'estaca à montigny le
bretonneux
mais tout d'abord une petite définition
réseaux d'entreprise ensemble
d'entreprises indépendantes qui
entretiennent des relations formelles
sous forme de contrats de franchise de
concession ou autre sans que des liens
financiers ne les unissent et vous allez
découvrir que dans cet épisode tous les
réseaux d'entreprise sans quentinois
mais tout d'abord le sommaire
l'agglomération de saint quentin en
yvelines regorge de réseaux d'entreprise
art sec 78 d'état sky ou encore plateau
leur but créer du lien entre les
sociétés nous recevrons laurent legendre
le président de delta sky un réseau cas
pour but la mise en contact
d'entreprises liées à l'aménagement le
logement et les services
et puis focus sur vd comme l'institut a
pour vocation de créer les véhicules de
demain pour finaliser ces projets
participent à des événements tels que
imagine mobility pour dénicher des
talents et nous procéderons plusieurs
réseaux à saint quentin
leur but est de mettre des entreprises
en avant et surtout de leur permettre
d'augmenter leurs contacts focus sur les
réseaux nous avons tout d'abord le
réseau plateau réunissant une
cinquantaine de dirigeants de pme comme
bouygues construction thales ou oraux
step delta sky qui a pour but d'aider en
ce qui concerne les transports le
logement et les services
créé le 1er juillet 2010 à l'initiative
des grandes entreprises du territoire
concerné par les plans de déplacement
interentreprises
on peut aussi parler du réseau créactive
un réseau d'entre aide pour femmes chefs
d'entreprise ou porteuses de projets un
réseau très engagé sur le territoire
avec ses rencontres
kreactive par exemple
il ya aussi le réseau convergence son
but favoriser les échanges entre les
chefs d'entreprises du bassin
d'activités de saint quentin en yvelines
de versailles grand parc et du plateau
de saclay et puis il y en a d'autres
comme le club fasse l'arseg 78 ou encore
business 78 et pour en discuter nous
recevons aujourd'hui sur le plateau
laurent legendre le président de delta
sky
bonsoir bonsoir merci de me recevoir
donc delta ce qui es tu un réseau un peu
particulier puisque c'est une
association donc beaucoup de réseaux
d'entreprises ont pour objet des choses
qui sont dans le core business des
entreprises glace
l'association delta c'est un peu
différent le but est de mieux travailler
avec le territoire et de faire en sorte
que les entreprises puissent mieux se
développer sur ce territoire en
interagissant donc avec les
institutionnels qui sont en charge du
fonctionnement du territoire comment
alors ça se passe de différentes façons
par exemple on a démarré sur une
problématique qui était la problématique
du transport de nos salariés
d'abord parce que les entreprises
étaient soumises à une obligation de
déposer des plans de déplacements
d'entreprise
et puis on s'est dit mais si chacun
demande des choses différentes ça va
être impossible et on n'améliorera pas
le système
donc il faut se fédérer d'où la création
de cette association et le travail que
l'on a monté avec le chambre direction
des transports pardon de saint quentin
en yvelines ainsi que la chambre de
commerce qui nous ont permis de
travailler directement avec le stif avec
les organisateurs la société des
transports ski bus et d'améliorer le
virus sur nos sens et avec le voir
parler bien sûr puisque nous avions
déposé des dossiers lors de la
commission du débat public et que
maintenant saint quentin en yvelines va
avoir une gare un horizon 2030 c'est un
petit peu tard mais
une garde sur la ligne 18 du grand paris
et dites moi ça se passe c'est des
réunions que vous faites avec plusieurs
acteurs des entreprises ça se passe
vraiment alors il y à différents modes
de fonctionnement nous avons d'abord nos
réflexions au sein d'un conseil
d'administration
et puis nous avons des réunions qui se
font avec les acteurs du territoire
notamment la direction des transports
nous nous organisons des ateliers sur
les transports
nous avons sept axes sur lesquels nous
développons des améliorations pour nos
salariés qui ont plus de facilités pour
venir dans nos entreprises donc nos
entreprises ont plus de facilités pour
recruter et ça c'est important et donc
elles sont également mieux intégrer le
territoire et elles restent sur le
territoire
ok mais bon vous savez quoi on va
continuer avec vous mais tout de suite
faisons un point sur vd comme elle fait
partie du réseau moveo un réseau qui
compte plus de 40 groupes plus de 200
pme et start-up plus de 40
établissements de recherche et
d'enseignement supérieur
bref un réseau d'envergure alors quels
sont les atouts majeurs de mauvais au
pour une entreprise la voiture de demain
viendra peut-être du site de satory en
effet bd comme l'institut pour la
transition énergétique créé en 2014
tente avec tous ces chercheurs de rendre
la voiture de demain
accessible à tous l'institut pour la
transition énergétique doit apporter
dans le domaine de la mobilité doit
apporter des solutions qui vont
favoriser l'efficacité de la mobilité
nous avons trois domaines de recherche
l'électrification des véhicules
d'une part le véhicule autonome comme on
dit est connecté et puis également les
nouveaux usages de la mobilité et les
aspects juridiques et clients de la
mobilité
versailles est centré s'est extrêmement
bien placé entre en particulier
de nos gros membres industriels que sont
psa et renault qui sont respectivement à
vélizy et à guyancourt et le réseau est
important pour cette entreprise qui a
besoin de grands groupes pour se
développer et ainsi faire avancer la
vingtaine de projets sur laquelle elle
travaille aujourd'hui que nous avons
comme que membre donc renault et peugeot
qui sont bien connus nous avons
également des équipementiers comme valeo
et continental nous avons également des
entreprises d'usagé ou de transport je
pourrais citer transdev qui fait partie
de nos de nos membres majeurs
enfin nous avons quelqu'un qui n'est pas
du monde de l'automobile mais qui est
très intéressé par le domaine
le domaine du moteur électrique qui est
safran on parle d' avion utilisant des
moteurs électriques de plus en plus et
ça les intéresse vd comme a profité de
l'événement imagine mobility organisée
par le réseau movéo pour créer de
nouvelles collaborations et bien sûr
présenté ses projets nous sommes
toujours avec laurent legendre le
président de delta ce qui dit moi vous
avez combien d'entreprises alors
actuellement nous avons une quarantaine
d'entreprises sur les sept communes
d'origine de saint quentin en yvelines
l'agglomération est passé à 12 donc
cette année nous sommes en phase
détendre
l'association et nous devrions compter à
peu près le double en fin d'année c'est
important
c'est très important parce que il faut
être représentatifs
on a démarré à une dizaine qui étaient
les grands groupes il y avait renault il
y avait bouygues
il y avait un talent s il y avait airbus
il ya maintenant safran nous a rejoint
des banques le crédit agricole
mais il faut aussi représenter les plus
petites entreprises
et c'est important parce que nous avons
aussi développé depuis quelques temps
des actions pour développer de
l'interaction business entre les grandes
et les petites entreprises dites moi
aujourd'hui je crée mon entreprise faut
que je fasse partie d'un réseau
alors c'est très important parce que
quand vous arrivez sur un territoire
vous avez besoin de développer votre
business votre business si vous êtes en
bigoudis il faut le développer avec les
autres entreprises du territoire donc le
réseau d'entreprise est très important
nous avons participé très activement au
ski business days l'an dernier pour la
première édition de 150 entreprises 3600
rendez vous donc c'est là que secret
l'interactivité et bien je vous remercie
d'être avec nous aujourd'hui sur
l'émission et nous on continue
faisons un point avec le directeur du
réseau de mauvais au que vous connaissez
un petit peu qu'ils étaient présents à
l'événement
imagine mobility
monsieur charles ix dites moi quels sont
les forces de mauvais haut
d'abord movéo ckoi à mauguio c'est un
pôle de compétitivité qui travaille dans
le secteur de la mobilité et de
l'automobile
un pôle de compétitivité c'est quoi
c'est une association qui réunit sur un
territoire des acteurs très divers les
start-up des pme des grands groupes des
laboratoires de recherche des
collectivités pour innover pour innover
ensemble
donc vous n'êtes pas un simple réseau de
contacts il ya vraiment tout un travail
qui était derrière comme bien sûr et
soeurs nous sommes un réseau au feder ce
ce réseau mais aussi on un accélérateur
donc on siens d'accélérateur pour toutes
ses entreprises ses laboratoires de
manière à ce qu'ils innovent en mode
collaboratif au sein de ce réseau
quelles sont les missions exactement que
vous avez tout au long de l'année j'ai
besoin qu'il ya beaucoup de choses à
faire
alors on n'a qu'à piller on a un premier
pilier qui est vraiment l'innovation
c'est ce que je vous disais c'est les
programmes de r&d collaboratifs ses
portes et l'innovation
un deuxième pilier qu'est le business on
accompagne aussi nos membres et surtout
les petites entreprises vers le business
on les aide à lever les freins d'accès
au marché on aide à passer de l'idée à
la concrétisation à la commercialisation
de l'île et donc il ya bien à plein de
verrous techniques mais aussi financier
a levé dont les as de la danse c'est le
2e pilier et un troisième pilier vous
l'avez cité c'est le réseau en un
animateur de cet écosystème donc il faut
l'animé ce réseau on organise des
événements des gros événements comme
aujourd'hui où on a 350 personnes
réunies mais aussi des tout petits
ateliers de travail qui permettent de
générer de nouveaux projets saas est le
troisième pays est le quatrième pilier
c'est les compétences les compétences la
formation c'est qu'est ce qu'on met en
place aujourd'hui comme type de
formation pour répondre aux besoins de
ce secteur de l'automobile à mobilité
qui a des besoins de plus en plus grand
avec des compétences qui n'existe pas
aujourd'hui donc il faut qu'on prévoit
les formations et c'est le cas
d'ailleurs illustre bien aujourd'hui on
fait cet événement à l'estaca qui est
une école d'ingénieurs qui forment les
ingénieurs de demain
et si demain allez je décidais de
changer de métier de
faire une petite start up dans la
mobilité je suis accepté directement et
dites-moi est-ce que c'est important
directement pour moi de vous intégrer
alors bien sûr il faut que vous veniez
tout de suite voire mauvais aux une fois
votre entreprise et créer un puisque
sont membres que des entreprises à des
personnes morales et une fois vous êtes
créée et nous on va être là pour vous
accélérez on va tout de suite vous faire
rentrer dans le réseau donc on va vous
faire connaître des bonnes personnes
vous mettre en contact avec les bonnes
personnes
on va vous aider à trouver des
financements soient des financements
publics il ya beaucoup d aide à la
création de pme start up soit des
financements privés on aide aussi à la
levée de fonds
et puis on va vous accompagner dans
votre démarche d'innovation à trouver
les bonnes solutions à lever vos verrous
technologiques pour que votre idée que
votre start-up puisse proposer une
solution sur le marché avec les bons
verrous le russe est en fait on va on va
vous booster on est un booster de
croissance c'est un peu le mot vo
booster de croissance dans le domaine de
la mobilité on va vous accélérez vous
booster pour trouver votre marché pour
finir c'est quoi la suite
mais la suite c'est continuer cette
superbe aventure movéo a fêté ses dix
ans l'année dernière
on espère que en 2026 on fêtera la no 20
ans avec toujours autant de dynamisme
autant de volonté de travailler en mode
collaboratif pour que la fin la france
reste dans la course de l'innovation et
restent compétitives sur ces domaines du
futur que sont les technologies pour la
mobilité
je vous le souhaite et jours mais je me
dis à bientôt et merci à bientôt et on
passe au journal de l'écho cette semaine
saint quentin en yvelines présenter sky
une veste son but est de au financement
des entreprises écoutez s'adresse à
toutes les start up pme toutes les
structures qu'on a des besoins de
financement pour financer leur
développement leur croissance qui
auraient un besoin de fonds propres
contre cent mille euros et 2005 et à
noter un nouvel appel à candidatures
pour les entrepreneurs souhaitant
intégrer le ski cube
les dossiers sont à déposer avant le 15
juin ecoutez jean luc méreau le
directeur de la structure
c'est un accompagnement très spécifique
technique et qui permet à ces jeunes
startups
d'avoir des informations des conseils de
la formation et un accompagnement
vraiment adapté à leurs besoins
vous avez entre 18 et 25 ans vous êtes
sortis du système scolaire depuis plus
d'un an sans diplôme ni qualification et
bien l'école de la seconde chance est
fait pour vous la formation est gratuite
et les élèves sont rémunérés en tant que
stagiaire de la formation
professionnelle
les prochaines admission auront lieu le
12 juin et le 11 septembre pour plus
d'informations rendez vous à l'école de
la seconde chance à trappes
c'est la fin de cette suite échos merci
de nous avoir suivis et surtout bonne
journée